du mercredi
[Musique]
je vous mets dans le coup on va y aller
le petit subterfuge je vais proposer aux
gens mais de leur lire l'horoscope
voulez-vous que je vous laisse votre
votre horoscope c'est gratuit j'ai leur
lire par contre mon signe à moi je vous
dis tout de suite je suis taureau et
puis ensuite on verra leur réaction quel
est votre signe Capricorne
faut-il du zodiaque c'est quoi moi c'est
taureau ça tombe aussi des recherches
entamées dans un domaine spécifique
touche enfin à leurs fins il ne reste
plus qu'à finir le boulot votre esprit
est particulièrement affûté c'est le
moment idéal pour vous a donné au
travail et en amour faut parler de
l'amour tout ça
la vie vous sourit vous prenez sans
doute toute la mesure de la force du
lien psychique qui vous unit ne lâchez
rien waouh magnifique l'avenir est
devant moi je suis remonté là
je termine un groupe projet justement
fait que ça le timing est bon tout est
beau quelle expérience vous attiré et
boboy 17 6 mais peut-être si je vous dis
que c'est pas votre signe zodiaque que
j'ai lu mais un autre ça serait dommage
que
parce qu'on peut on peut sortir des
généralités qui vont toucher un peu tout
le monde en ce moment c'est un peu dans
l'air du temps et ça répond à quel
besoin
connaître l'inconnu d'avance ou je sais
pas est-ce que vous savez faire partie
de votre quotidien Le Matin prendre un
café regardez la section des horoscopes
non
pourquoi je pense pas vraiment qu'un
douzième de la planète va vivre la même
journée j'avais une conversation sur la
Lune avec mon ado là c'est juste que la
lune quand elle est pleine on la voit
plus donc si il se passe de quoi puis on
voit la pleine lune mais on associe en
tout cas ce qui vous est dit dans cette
cette horoscope forterafruit puis vous
amènera des moments heureux merci
crois-tu que la mouette une opinion
là-dessus
quel signe du zodiaque
[Musique]
l'horoscope les cartes du ciel
l'alignement des astres Mercure
rétrograde mais voilà des termes des
concepts des croyances qui connaissent
un regret de popularité depuis
l'avènement de la pandémie les mots-clés
que liés à l'astrologie génère désormais
des dizaines de milliards de vues sur
des plateformes comme Tik Tok à travers
cet engouement bien souvent une quête de
sens d'introspection et de repères les
mêmes motivations depuis des millénaires
mais toujours la même absence de base
scientifique
mais Marie-Pierre d'abord bravo pour ce
choix vestimentaire tout à fait
circonstance c'est tout à fait de
circonstances aussi qu'on se parle ici
on est au planétarium Rio Tinto Alcan
new par excellence pour apprendre à
connaître la science puisque c'est ça
donc question une mission scientifique
ici de faire connaître l'astronomie qui
n'est pas l'astrologie de choses
complètement différentes c'est là où le
bobeless mais il y a une recrudescence
en ce moment de l'intérêt envers
l'astrologie pourquoi l'astrologie
Marie-Pierre ne passe pas le test de la
science cette fois Alexis j'ai
moyennement envie de répondre à cette
question là commence mal parce qu'en
science on n'aime pas ça de voir prouver
la négative on en parle souvent et à la
limite ce serait pas aussi scientifique
de démontrer en quoi l'astrologie ne
tient pas la route mais aux astrologues
de démontrer en quoi la position des
astres pourrait influencer notre
comportement notamment et chaque fois
qu'ils ont essayé
ça a pas fonctionné je pense entre
autres à une recherche qui a été publiée
dans la revue Nature ça fait quand même
un bon bout de temps en 1985 on avait
donné des astrologues des cartes du ciel
qui avait été faite pour différentes
personnes pour chacune de ces
personnes-là ont donné trois
descriptions de leur personnalité et les
astrologues devaient associer la bonne
carte du ciel avec la bonne description
de personnalité
les résultats ils ont réussi une fois
sur trois aucune recherche qui est venue
démontrer que les astrologues font mieux
que le hasard donc en attendant cette
fameuse recherche là qui qui apporterait
de l'eau au moulin prétendre que la
position des astres influence le cours
des événements les personnalités des
gens c'est aussi aberrant que de
prétendre que la position des avions
dans le ciel influence notre
comportement ou encore que il existe des
aspirateurs bionniques pas trop le
cosmos pour faire un peu de ménage une
fois de temps en temps ça non plus on ne
peut pas prouver que c'est faux puis
cette espèce de stratégie là de on peut
pas prouver que c'est faux gardons
l'esprit ouvert c'est pas seulement pour
l'astrologie c'est très Dadon on voit
souvent ça pour toute forme de pseudo
science oui ça me rappelle Marie-Pierre
qu'on avait au décrypteurs à la première
saison des décrypteurs tenter d'aborder
le thème des platistes de ceux qui
avancent que la terre est plate malgré
des des siècles et des siècles de
preuves scientifique on n'aime pas ça
prouver par la négative mais joue en jeu
d'accord quand même allons-y bon en quoi
ça ça fonctionne plus ou moins on
pourrait peut-être commencer avec
ce qui serait l'outil marketing numéro 1
des astrologues les constellations ces
fameuses constellations là dans le fond
c'est une pure invention humaine les
étoiles qui forment les constellations
elles ont aucun lien entre elles là à
part les lignes imaginaires qu'on trace
la discussion là elles sont situées à
des distances très très différentes les
unes des autres on parle
d'années-lumière donc des milliers de
milliards de kilomètres si on se plaçait
à un autre endroit que la terre dans
l'univers
ils existeraient plus ces formes
imaginaires là donc les constellations
invention purement humaines les fameux
mouvements rétrogrades
rétrograde dans le fond ce sont des
mouvements apparents il y a rien qui se
passe mercure et fait sa petite course
autour du soleil non elle change pas de
direction ça c'est un raisonnement qui a
du sens dans une optique où on
ignore tout du fonctionnement du système
solaire donc ça c'était le cas très très
longtemps à cette époque là oui quand on
pense que la terre et le centre de
l'univers et que tout tourne autour de
nous c'est certain que ça peut être
bouleversant d'avoir l'impression qu'une
planète change soudainement de
merci une impression c'est pas ça qui se
passe donc d'aller on devrait même pas
utiliser cette expression là d'une dire
d'une planète qu'elle rétrograde ça n'a
aucun sens mais en plus d'aller donner
des propriétés paranormales à ça ça
c'est pire qu'un ensemble c'est dû gros
n'importe quoi c'est aussi absurde dans
le fond que ça faisait des petites
blagounettes là à chaque fois
qu'il y a un orage ben on dit que eux
c'est pas content puis nous pitch des
éclairent c'est du même niveau ok voilà
pour Zeus mais quand même je continue à
jouer le jeu avec toi Marie-Pierre
disons qu'au-delà de ces mouvements
apparents qui n'en sont pas il y a des
forces connues de la science qui exerce
qu'il faut en sorte que les astres
exercent une influence sur nous est-ce
qu'en quelque part on pourrait
s'approcher de quelque chose qui se peut
non on va faire l'inventaire des forces
dont on dispose en sciences et en existe
4 des forces fondamentales il y a la
gravité l'électromagnét la force
nucléaire forte la force nucléaire
faible puis la seule qui serait
potentiellement susceptible
éventuellement d'avoir une influence la
des distances aussi grandes à ces
échelles ce serait la gravité ok la
gravité plus les objets sont massifs
plus élégants plus les objets sont
rapprochés l'un de l'autre plus vous
allez forte aussi ça diminue
drastiquement avec la distance et puis
là si on fait quelques calculs coûtent
la gravité exercée par les planètes du
système solaire elle est beaucoup plus
faible
la force qu'elle exerce sur nous que
celle de la lune ou du soleil alors que
tout ça a la même importance en
astrologie mais la lune
avait une influence sur les marées ce
qu'on pense que j'essaye encore
dans cette perspective là ça peut avoir
une influence on a fait une capsule
là-dessus
on peut encore visionner en ligne mais
grosso modo l'attraction
gravitationnelle lorsqu'il fait
finalement que la Lune c'est assez sur
les océans pour créer des marées c'est
une force qui augmente avec la masse qui
diminue avec la distance
côté masse on est d'accord que la masse
de l'eau contenue dans un corps humain
et de beaucoup inférieur à la masse de
l'eau contenue dans un océan on est
d'accord puis la distance joue pour
beaucoup la lune l'air de rien et
tellement éloignée nous que c'était un
des effets saillants de notre capsule
une mouche qui se pose sur nous va
exercer notre action gravitationnelle
plus forte sur l'eau contenue dans notre
corps que la Lune mais somme toute là
l'astrologie faut bien se dire que ça
amuse les gens quelque part regarde son
horoscope le matin dans le Journal
est-ce que c'est pas Bénin en quelque
part oui ça peut être relativement
inoffensif si on a le même rapport avec
elle modèle qu'on a avec par exemple les
biscuits chinois à la fin d'un repas ou
le fameux Choixpeau de Harry Potter qui
décide si on fait partie des Gryffondors
ou des Serpentards tout le monde s'amuse
bien on le sait que c'est un peu
n'importe quoi mais c'est très ludique
le problème avec l'astrologie c'est que
ça vient avec toute une aura
scientifique un jargon scientifique
parfois donc il y a confusion des genres
contrairement à nos biscuits chinois ou
notre Choixpeau puis notre sens critique
c'est important qu'on garde affûter et
dans cet esprit là je trouve ça un petit
peu dommage que il y a des journaux et
des magazines qui ont encore une page
horoscope mais qu'ils ont aucune page
science c'est dommage en effet au nom du
sens critique oui les étoiles ont une
influence sur nous oui il existe un lien
profond entre l'homme et le cosmos
ne serait-ce que parce que le soleil une
étoile il est là puis c'est grâce à lui
qu'on est en vie mais aussi tous les
atomes dont on est tricoté ils ont été
créés par les étoiles donc nous sommes
des poussières d'étoiles
c'est bon c'est immense mais c'est tout
tout le reste ça nous appartient le ciel
rien à voir avec ça